tomorrow my bad boys bakery start
selling cakes bread and tarts to the UK
public for the first time in our one day
only
heading up the bakery Kelly who is
clearly a natural-born seller that Shane
has made me change
I mean living the world life that's all
fights or bollocks it's all folks first
step by changing the neon blue tape
I've got to take responsibility for my
actions so I've got three lovely kids
it's about time I [ __ ] grew up with
all parabolics aunt Leigh
I just can't how many loaves are there
pleased with the ovens fired up the
kitchen's really delivering on bread and
scones but there's a major problem with
the lemon treacle tarts
honesty honesty who lined this look
they'll never cook [ __ ] want to waste
the time I didn't anticipate that
mass-producing these tarts would be so
difficult and this is supposed to be the
centerpiece product of the bad boys
Baker absolute [ __ ] disaster vessels
going on total waste of time effort
money disaster have got one tart cooks
will be going for three hours everybody
else has been producing great scones
great bread of the back and here we're
looking we're looking stupid and the
bomb drops I've been called to see
Jerome's senior officer on a wing Andy
Cole yeah he wants have a word because
he wants the king showing off the course
so the disciplinary hearing may have
been delayed for a week but mr. Cole has
his own opinion of what should happen to
Jerome on the discipline side he is an
absolute nightmare he is on basic is so
disrespectful to staff and when he comes
back on the wing he's demanding this
demand in there all right it's just
unfortunate what you're telling me I
totally respect but I don't see any of
that to that level inside that kitchen
no but from my point of view as a
discipline so you know officer we would
like him removed if he was 32 and it'd
been around the block a few times and I
would 100% agree with you get him out of
there what I would like to ask for it's
just a bit more time just to convince
you and I'll have a word with him he
needs to knuckle down and he can't walk
in here like King dick and he can't
start treating the officers like he's
untouchable
he's gonna be showing some yourself I'm
gonna make your own my personal project
I'm gonna stick my neck out and keep him
in the kitchen but only works out for
you
come back Devil's kitchen mr. Cole he
thinks is a big privilege but if we
don't give these guys a chance and
tolerate that for a certain amount of
time in order to get through this this
systems ever going to change tonight in
this prison not in any prison so it's
just as [ __ ] annoying I mean it
really is annoying
[Music]
what they say you are making a heart
they want you off the course and I don't
want you off the course we can't go back
on that wing and act like King dick just
keep your mouth shut I tried to ignore
them but it's time to bring up the old
core knocks no-necks asleep
no can win all the time sandwich
sandwich sandwich but listen to me you
get kicked off this and letting me go
don't fight against them it's the system
okay
let's go